- You saw me sing with my next
guest earlier in the show.
He's one of the most talented artists
in country music today.
His latest album is called
"Sunday Drive" and it's out now.
You should get it if you're cool.
Give it up for Brett Eldredge, everybody.
(audience cheering)
I know, it's so weird.
I have guests here and I can't hug them.
- I know, I love hugging too.
- I know me too.
It's like a southern thing,
I guess, I don't know.
- [Brett] I'm making myself
at home, is that cool?
- Yes, I actually we were discussing this-
- Can I have this couch when we're done?
- It's a really cool couch.
It's a lovely color of it.
- It's awesome.
I got the red and the green right here.
I feel very festive.
- I know.
You're very Christmasy, yes.
Well, thank you for singing with me.
- Are you kidding?
It was amazing.
- I was very excited.
You can ask Shane, our friend,
we have a mutual friend.
And we were talking about it earlier,
that we hadn't met until today,
and so we had to record it
separate, or separately rather.
But have you ever done that?
Have you ever recorded a duet?
- I did with Meghan Trainor.
- [Kelly] You never met her and you never?
- No, I knew her, but we
were in the middle of tour.
And we did "Baby, It's Cold Outside."
- Oh my gosh, I love that song.
- And it was awesome.
But, yeah, we knew each
other, but we never-
- But you had at least met.
- Yeah, I've never done it like this.
- I know, I don't know if
I've ever not met the person.
- But I met you, when I
heard your voice, I was like,
♪ Ah ♪
And then we sang, it was awesome.
- Same, what are like your...
Like for me to know it's Christmas
is hearing Bing Crosby's
"White Christmas."
And I heard that that's
one of your favorites.
- That's the song, the cassette.
So my dad had the
cassette back in the day.
- [Kelly] A cassette.
- You know, I'd go to
the glove compartment.
It's about, you know,
November, around right now.
And you just open that glove compartment
and there's Bing Crosby's
"White Christmas."
And I popped it in there as a little kid.
And I'm listening to this
old man sing his heart out.
And it just like,
I think that's when I got my old soul.
Like I feel like I had an old soul.
And that's when I started
loving Christmas music
and the magic of it.
And Bing Crosby just did it for me.
- Okay, so mine was not only Bing Crosby,
but Rosemary Clooney,
because they were both
in "White Christmas."
I was obsessed.
- Probably my favorite movie.
- All right, well, the title track
on Brett's new album, "Sunday
Drive," is about his family.
He sings, "It's the ordinary
things that means so much.
That's where I learned it all from them.
To fight, to love, to laugh again.
Man, I thought we were only wasting time
out on the 'Sunday Drive.'"
I like the simplicity of that lyric
and what it represents for so many people.
And you did, you thought it was just
kind of like we're wasting time.
- Yeah, I mean, I still go back
to like after a baseball game as a kid
eating Dairy Queen in
the back of the car like,
and spilling cookie dough
blizzard all over myself.
- But that's so beautiful.
Those are those nostalgic moments.
- You think those moments are,
you know, you don't
realize it at the moment.
And the next thing you know,
you get older and you're in high school
and rolling the windows down,
and the music's blaring
and you feel alive.
And then next thing you know,
you're grown up and you
realize how quick time goes.
And it's making the moments count
and with the ones you love, so.
- Totally, and it really hits you
I think when you pass those places.
It's like you pass a Dairy Queen,
or you smell a certain scent
that reminds you of something.
- Oh, right back.
- Yeah, it's a really cool
idea for a song, clever.
I heard you took a very different approach
to writing this record.
You kind of like went off the grid,
right?
- Yeah.
- So I-
- Like how off the grid?
- I was heavily on all the
social media and everything,
and just constantly on my phone.
And I was like, "I gotta just
step away from everything.
Take some time for myself."
I got a flip phone.
- A flip phone.
Like, wait, oh my gosh.
- Yeah, I mean,
straight up hang up on somebody
and close it, you know.
Make a point kind of thing.
- The only thing better
would've been a beeper.
But okay.
- Yeah, that's next.
That's my next stage for my next album.
But it just really made me kind of focus
on myself for a while
and just kind of figure
out what I wanted to say,
who I wanted to be.
I started journaling a lot more.
I got a Polaroid camera.
I was taking photos actually
making every one count.
Every picture wasn't perfect.
You know, when you have a phone you're,
you can take 4,000 pictures and pick one.
It's like Polaroid, you
gotta make that moment count.
So just doing stuff like
that really made me,
you know, reflective of my life,
where I was, and where I am,
and where I wanna go with it.
- Slow it down and appreciate it.
- Slow it down, yep.
- [Kelly] So I think that's
why I love this record so much.
- There's never a moment for yourself.
- It feels real, like a real album.
- Yes, well thank you.
- Yeah, and actually,
I think it was Blake and
or Gwen, one of them,
is the one who turned
me on to it at first.
And I was like, "Oh."
I was like, "I gotta check that out."
But it's really well done as in an album.
It sounds like an album.
- Well, thank you.
- Yeah.
- Well, I appreciate that.
- Yeah, well done.
Well, Brett's album, "Sunday
Drive," is available now.
If you're cool, you'll go get it.